can someone please explain to me what
the hell guy fieri ever did to anyone
y'all know who I'm talking about the
celebrity chef people [ __ ] on that dude
all the time and as far as I can tell
all he ever did was follow his dreams
you understand people are horrible to a
television personality and he didn't do
anything wrong here's what he did do
America he started a company where he
hires everybody
he pays more than minimum wage he gives
health benefits before he has to he has
a non-profit where he gives pretzel
making machines to schools so they can
fundraise I know that one sounds like I
made it up but I swear to Christ it's
true he works with Special Olympics
athletes and if you need a little more
sugar with this medicine he also
officiated a gay wedding yeah but
because he has flames on his shirt
everybody shits all over this dude like
he's a member of Nickelback and by the
way what the hell did Nickelback ever do
they made 40 million bros happy yeah you
don't want them walking around pissed
off that's how we ended up in this mess
that should bother a hoof vehicle Hey
look I get it I don't want to hang out
with Guy Fieri either okay I know he
looks like a hot topic manager
moonlighting at a Fridays didn't do
anything wrong
well what else has he done Shane I'm so
glad you asked he goes around the
country to small businesses and gives
them free advertising on a national
platform on a weekly basis advertising
those small businesses could never
afford themselves with his own
television show but because his hair
looks like he was electrocuted while
drinking Mountain Dew people act like we
need to saw his head off and put it on
the Internet
meanwhile y'all can't get enough of
Anthony Bourdain and he seems like the
kind of dude that would be mean to dogs
so I don't understand what is happening
so I put on Rolling Stones t-shirts and
I tell food courts they suck come on
like if you had to choose between being
stuck in a foxhole with Anthony Bourdain
or Guy Fieri you gonna pick the area
every time
I am still doing this bit what what's
more Dana do I'll tell you it'll be like
that dude in every World War 2 movie who
sucks the whole time then when the Nazis
show up doesn't do his job it's a bunch
of good soldiers killed meanwhile Guy
Fieri's over here earning new nicknames
like el fuego picking up live grenades
throwing them back saying dope [ __ ] like
welcome to flavortown and he knows he's
dying on that beach in France that
morning but he's there [ __ ] and what
do y'all do you [ __ ] all over him just
cuz he had his sunglasses on the back of
his neck I think it's awesome that he
has a racing stripe painted on his
fridge love it if Banksy had painted it
and look guys I know I look like the
kind of dude that would defend Guy Fieri
but if that's what you're taking away
from this you're missing the point
thank you guys very much I'm Shankar
[Applause]
you